in the 5-4 decision with Justice Kennedy
writing of the majority the court said
the decision was effective right away
meaning they didn't send the case back
to the lower courts to decide the issue
they made the decision saying that the
ban on gay marriage violated the 14th
amendment or the Equal Protection Clause
and that marriages in one state must be
recognized by other states by taking gay
marriage off the table the Supreme Court
gave conservatives and the GOP a push in
the libertarian direction Republicans
and especially presidential candidates
may use the Court's rulings to drum up
cash for their campaigns for their most
socially conservative constituents but
it's not going to last more libertarian
parts of the GOP will eventually take
over leaving guys like these in the dust
the decision didn't answer what will
happen in the future for those that care
about religious freedom you know those
Christian wedding cake bakers who aren't
keen on making anything for a gay
wedding in their dissent Robertson Alito
said that religious people need to worry
about this decision and that these cases
are bound to come up in the future it's
rare that all of the dissenters write
their own descent at the Supreme Court
they usually join the majority's
dissenting opinion on the case but it's
clear that the four justices wanted to
make their mark on the case and have
their say in history click here for more
coverage of the gay marriage decision
before the Supreme Court